Benny you you've spoken before about how
in many ways this conflict has now
become a sort of broader Clash of
civilizations there is a clash of
civilizations if you like but it's part
of the Clash of civilizations between
the Muslim World essentially in my view
or if you like the extremist Muslim
world but I fear it's the Muslim World
in fact and the West the values of these
two worlds are completely different and
they're clashing continuously in the
streets of Belgium however where a
Muslim yesterday murdered two swedes
because they were Christians or infidels
The Clash in Palestine is part of it and
the Turkish Muslim destruction of the
Christian minorities 100 years ago is
part of it these are all parts of this
Clash of
civilizations